every esport has
its pillars those people that you think
of immediately
as soon as you say its name maybe it's
an incredible
once in a generation player speaker
flashes into the brush back to his he
jackie love
lying in wait but it doesn't matter and
faker still the greatest player in the
world
or maybe it's an influential pro turned
content creator
i mean i kind of felt like i was doing
the same thing you were doing right
or maybe it's the game's most memorable
one-hit wonder
[Music]
is your smash summit a champion
did it he's done it a pikachu has won a
major smash summit
but when it comes to shaping the core
identity of an entire scene
very few people have impacted their
community
more than james chen the fgc's iconic
crying commentator as a bonafide fgc
historian james was a content creator
for the games he loved
way before content creation was even a
thing painting
a portrait of fighting games throughout
the years with blood
sweat and literal tears like so hard
to get emotional we should have like uh
instead of a staring contest we can have
a crying contest we'll just
we'll just talk about evo until one of
us cries so how did this
feline loving sensitive soul of a man
help shape the fgc into what it is today
and what was it that made james chen
want to champion a scene that
seemingly no one else cared about it's
height
it's just pure hype and energy you just
don't get that
from i really honestly don't feel like
you get that
from any other esport oh
that's it that's it is the evolution
2017 champion coming all the way from
luther's bracket
he's done it
hey guys it's dimitri now fighting back
tears at evo
may not be easy but you know what is
switching to geico
15 minutes could save you 15 or more on
car insurance
be sure to check out the link in the
description below alright so if there's
one thing you should know about the most
famous weeper in all of esports it's
that his career could have gone down
any number of paths for instance you may
not know this but
he could have started his own moving
business
go get mad get mad
or he could have dedicated his life to
dropping bars
panoramic view look i'll make it all
manageable they can choose
all you different crews chicks and dudes
who used to make us really kick in too
and if he didn't pursue his obvious
musical talents
he could have simply indulged his
immense love of cats
by becoming a vet okay we've got cats
all over the place here i've got one on
my lap by the way
but fortunately for all of us james
decided to forgo
all of those enticing options in favor
of something else entirely
choosing instead to devote himself body
and soul
to one particular pursuit what do i do i
love the fighting game community that's
what i do
as the old esports cliche goes james was
first introduced to what would become
his life's calling by his older brother
back in the early 90s but it was when
james first laid eyes on street fighter
2 that he fell head over heels in love
it was just
so beautiful and when you first started
playing it i don't know like even to
this day
if i just picture walking into an arcade
and hearing dolphin elephants
like on his background and just the old
voices and sound effects
i get chills like his brother james
began attending ucla
and it wasn't long before he became an
active member of the school's burgeoning
arcade fighting game scene
after he graduated james took a bit of a
step back from fighting games
but try as he might to focus on other
aspects of his life
he just couldn't resist their allure
especially when
capcom vs snk dropped in 1999
reigniting his interest tenfold
and this time around james wasn't just
playing fighting games
in his spare time he could be found
frequenting early online fgc
message boards helping to kickstart
conversations between the different
fighting game hotspots
all across the united states and abroad
and while james wasn't involved in
putting together evo's predecessor
battle by the bay in 1996 he wanted to
help with its successors
b4 and b5 in any way that he could even
though those events paled in comparison
to what would come later down the road
before b5 were all probably about the
same
just a little bit bigger maybe like over
a hundred people
and again that was in a very very small
arcade in folsom california
and i remember that that was packed as
well it was another situation where it
was just like
inside the arcade was just nothing but
hot and sweaty guys you know just
standing all you know packed like
sardines
but as small as those tournaments were
james believed that they were the start
of something great
and even though he enjoyed attending and
participating in them
he was inspired to get more involved in
the production side of things
you know it's tough organizing these
kind of events and i just wanted to make
myself helpful and i tried my best
to be helpful and say hello to my kitty
here oh okay
excuse me kitty you know i i just i
liked being helpful and i wanted to do
stuff
and then you know i started
transitioning to doing a lot of the
trailers and stuff like that because
i just really started enjoying doing
video editing i used to make combo
videos
now of course you can't make a great
trailer without
decent footage so in an attempt to
ensure that the fgc was well represented
james began capturing moments that no
one else thought to
and the truth is that if he hadn't we
might have had to rely solely on word of
mouth to know what the american fgc
looked like in its infancy when i
qualified for top eight at evo in 2003
james chen took my picture
for the top eight intros and after that
i thought whoa james chan
just took my picture so that was the
level
ironically in an effort to preserve and
promote these early fgc events for
future generations
james found himself with less and less
time to actually
play the games themselves and sure it
wasn't like he ever reached the
competitive heights of a digo or justin
wong
but he was still a passionate player one
who had developed
quite a reputation for his hilarious
bouts of rage
and for locking in some pretty
unconventional picks
a lot of people think that i'm i love
cami because waifu and i'm just like oh
she's like
no it's because she's sucked in super
turbo she's the worst character in super
turbo
and i wanted to be good at the worst
character in the game
memes aside by about 2008 the fgc
was facing a challenge of its own the
scene had started to become
stagnant at the time street fighter's
latest release
third strike was nearly a decade old
and as fewer developers released new
fighting games
people's interest and engagement in the
genre really took a hit
in 2008 i still remember at one point
looking around the room and going
i know like almost everybody here
like i'm not seeing new faces but just
when it was beginning to look as if
all was lost capcom dropped street
fighter
4 and everything changed commentator
talking directly to the players now
oh no it's all going to come right down
to this tiger oh
takes it and justin must admit that was
an excellent match and the crowd is on
its feet
evo 2009 breathed new life into the fgc
almost three times more people attended
than the year prior its production value
skyrocketed
and as a result broadcast talent had
suddenly become
more important than ever for me it was
it was probably one of the most defining
moments of my life because honestly
if it wasn't for that evo 2009 and i
probably wouldn't even still be here you
know i still wouldn't be here doing
commentary and all that stuff like that
it was
it was that crazy of a of a moment and
it was that
impactful of a year and really really
took fighting games to that next level
and
uh you know i like i said that that
post-tournament
feeling is permanently like etched into
my brain
now from that point on james decided
that his expertise
would best serve the fgc through
commentary
rather than as a competitor and thanks
to that fateful decision
he has blessed us with some classic
sound bites
over the years but those claps have just
been really hurting
they just slap him in the face he's
trying to slap him in the face
give him another hand
alex grabbing him with the ultra too
mine this is not going to be enough
quite yet but he's right there
what's the firework and it just
overhands him
alex fights
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god are you
kidding me are you kidding me are you
kidding me
oh he didn't get it in time did he get
him he did he did
how much damage is this gonna do not
gonna kill needs more
now if it wasn't obvious already just
because he wasn't competing
that didn't mean that james was any less
invested in the outcome of matches
if anything taking his own personal
saltiness over losing
out of the equation actually freed him
to loosen up
and have fun as a commentator criticism
now of course if you are a prominent
figure in a competitive gaming scene for
decades
like james chances are you're gonna be
tied to a number of different memes
but over the years there is one that is
truly in dear james to the fgc
the fact that it is simply impossible
for him
not to wear his heart on his sleeve the
man simply
oozes passion like he literally excretes
it from his eyeballs
and it's to the point where evo just
isn't evo unless james ends the show
with
tears rolling down his cheeks as someone
accomplishes their dreams
2017 champion coming all the way from
losers bracket
he's done it he has won evolution
finally
he's been chasing it for so long
and there it is tokido with his first
street fighter first place finish
here at evolution just one thing
i want to say fighting game is
something so great
[Music]
it's it's funny because i get so
emotional about this every year but you
know what like
tokido said it best there's no other
better way to say it fighting games are
great
why did you have to say that i know
that's you guys don't know that's what
got james the worst
it almost got me too i won't lie
[Applause]
and honestly can you blame the guy for
getting emotional
for the better part of 30 years he has
dedicated his
life to ensuring that the fgc could grow
into what it is today he's lived through
its darkest moments
and its euphoric highs and for him
being able to look back on that
transformation is proof enough that his
efforts weren't in vain and that's
something that even
legends of the scene have shown him
gratitude for
how are you doing thank you for your
hard work
[Laughter]
when we were at battle by the bay when
we had our first gathering there was
like
a whole 60 people like enter that
tournament was like ridiculous and like
to see it be at this extent like this is
new even for me
it's like seeing your child grow up and
be like the success
now unfortunately just like the rest of
the world the fgc
took quite a beating in 2020. the
arrival of the coveted 19 pandemic meant
that lan events
the lifeblood of the fgc were put on
hold
for a scene built upon the sacred
tradition of
popping off right beside your opponent
in front of a packed room of hyped-up
onlookers
fighting games may have suffered more
than any other esport
especially thanks to their terrible
netcode and while james hasn't been able
to physically attend events and see
friends he's known for
decades in person he told wccf tech that
he remains
optimistic that fighting games are only
going to return stronger
anything that comes out of this pandemic
really the positive
is that you know this has really kind of
put that focus on the on the netcode and
and you know uh made it loud enough i
think
for a lot of the japanese devs to
understand that in order to succeed in
other countries
where our internet infrastructure is uh
awful you know
that we kind of need this kind of thing
perhaps that romantic
optimism more than anything is what
makes james
such a lovable and inspiring figure he
hasn't just been a constant force of
positivity and change
but he's become a trusted caretaker for
an entire community
that has produced some of competitive
gaming's most unforgettable moments
and beautiful storylines and by assuming
that role
not only has he been able to preserve
the rich history of the scene
but he's helped to usher in a new
generation of passionate fans
players content creators and broadcast
talent
that will ensure that fighting games are
here to stay
and in spite of its recent struggles for
james
helping the fgc get to where it is today
remains his life's
greatest achievement a testament to what
a few
devoted individuals can do when they
truly believe in something
street fighter for me i mean i've been
playing it so much of my life
it's it practically is my life at this
point and you know
the thing about it is like to some
people it's like that's weird that it's
a video game or whatever like that but
you know everybody needs that thing in
their life to keep pushing them forward
and to draw them and
and just keep driving them and stuff
like that and so for me
street fighter is that thing as it
stands
james will have to continue fighting the
good fight from a safe distance
until life and lands return back to
normal
but when that time comes i think we can
all agree
that we know exactly where we'll find
him uh i think james is going to say it
all for me tonight
i didn't do it this time give it up for
james bring it in james
i love you man i love you
we'll see you next year dude marvel is
the goatee sport
actually the goatee sport shout out to
that dude at ti3
who if you go watch the official
broadcast for international 13
there's a guy who held up a sign a ti3
at the finals that just says when's
marvel
shout out to that dude whoever that dude
is you're doing god's work sir
bring it back dude like dude give me
some marvel you know what i mean like
oh that was so fire oh it's mama baby
oh dude it was so good